athènes comme tous les matins
grigoris début de sa tournée
ce grec de 52 ans ne compte pour vivre
aujourd'hui que sur le contenu de cette
petite boîte ça c'est ce que je vends
mes échantillons
c'est spécial pour les animaleries là je
vais lui en proposait voir si ça
l'intéresse
des aimants publicitaire de 20 à 40
centimes d'euros pièce avec lesquels
grigoris décroche à peine un sourire
c'est bien pour toi ça va directement
sur le frigo du client avec ton numéro
de téléphone non là non ça ne
m'intéresse pas les temps sont durs un
oui on fait des économies surtout
quelqu'un qui n'a pas à manger tu crois
qu'il va nourrir son animal des
arguments comme une rengaine pour
grégory ce qui remballe sa marchandise
les nouveaux clients sont rares alors le
vendeur relance les anciens
[Musique]
j'ai reçu le calendrier de 2012 tu le
veux je dors celui de 2012 qu'il a déjà
bon allez ok je n'avais pas aux
rigoristes force la main pour tout au
plus une vague promesse dans sa commande
ouais non cela allez c'est bon c'est
fait regarde ça regarde celui là
c'est un bon client je les ai perdus il
a fermé et maintenance est alloué et
bien sûr quand y'a une sandwicherie
comme ça qu'ils ferment il ya un prêteur
sur gages qui courent
celui là il prend tous des bagues des
alliances même les dents en or
grigoris citoyens d'un pays où la
prospérité n'a été que fiction un pays
aux incroyable scénario avant la crise
ce vendeur dément travailler dans le
cinéma dans la production ils gagnaient
5000 euros par mois
mais le film s'est arrêtée en faillite
la grèce est brusquement revenu à la
réalité
alors comment vit-on dans ce pays en
ruine financière
nous vous raconteront l'histoire de
zacharias est fonctionnaire dont le
revenu a été quasiment divisé par trois
les grecs sont nombreux à travailler
chaque jour sans recevoir de salaire
c'est le cas de mes ripping journalistes
à athènes
ceux qui souffrent mais aussi ceux qui
continuent à s'enrichir sans avoir à
payer plus d'impôts comme nikos vers
nikos armateurs à athènes voici les
visages de la crise grecque
une nation de 11 millions d'habitants à
peine qui risque toujours d'emporter
l'europe dans sa tourmente
[Musique]
pour finir sa tournée
rigaud rice a rendez vous avec une amie
[Musique]
elle s'appelle kate et elle est
architecte
c'est généralement la cliente de la
dernière chance mais cette fois il ne
peut pas compter sur elle
débordé ta commande on va l'étudier
on va voir si on a des finances et si on
a un gouvernement
j'espère qu'on en aura un si on en a un
et si la situation se stabilise pour
deux mois on prendra ta commande
ok il faut vraiment deux mois de
stabilité pour acheter des aimons bien
sûr rend un de nos client qui veut juste
rénové sa cuisine ou faire des travaux
ils hésitent
il se demande s'il va avoir les moyens
si la grèce va rester dans l'euro si on
va revenir à la monnaie nationale
on ne parle que de ça toute la journée
tu vois comment tout cela des
conséquences sur moi qu'était-il
l'architecte est marié à stelios un
entrepreneur un couple très
complémentaires elle dessine les
immeubles ils les construit aujourd'hui
kate et stelios ont perdu 80% de leurs
revenus
on va le comprendre en visitant l'un de
leurs chantiers la maison d'uranium
alors bienvenue salut orania ça va oui
ça va tu profites de ta maison est bon
on va où dans ta cuisine ou dans ton
salon plus
[Musique]
urena est prof de français elle gagne
1200 euros elle avait décidé de
restaurer cette maison pour y habiter
avec son mari et ses deux enfants
il y a deux ans elle avait demandé un
prêt à la banque
cent mille euros la banque avait accepté
en grèce à l'époque on prêtait
volontiers aux fonctionnaires ce serait
une première chambre et là ce serait une
deuxième chambre et les couleurs c'est
pas volontaire stelios l'entrepreneur a
déjà fait une partie des travaux il a
avancé les frais là il faut recouvrir la
pierre d'un enduit nous on n'a plus de
fonds si les fonds manquent c'est
qu'entre temps la crise s'est accélérée
le salaire durrani a abaissé bientôt
elle ne touchera plus que 900 euros par
mois alors la banque hésite kadhafi kft
apr 11 septembre
le dossier avait été acceptée je
remplissait toutes les conditions
mais tout d'un coup ils nous ont dit
qu'ils voulaient d'autres papiers de
plus en plus de garanties vous savez
comme les banques n'ont plus de
liquidités
elle freine des quatre fers soc
du coup le chantier bloqué urania doit
payer un loyer pour se loger qui a été
l'architecte et son mari entrepreneur en
sont pour leurs frais un chantier en
faillite
à l'image de la grèce pour anya vient de
trouver une lettre sur les gravats il
s'agit d'une taxe immobilière adossé à
la facture d'électricité
un nouvel impôt dont doivent s'acquitter
tous les grecs qui possède une maison
équipée d'un compteur électrique
ce bâtiment est concerné par la nouvelle
loi
donc on demanda urania se faire un
premier versement de 260 euros de taxes
sans qu'elles aient consommé de
l'électricité jusqu'à pas mal enchaîné
[Musique]
chez les voisins les travaux sont aussi
suspendues comme la plupart des
chantiers du pays
comme cette école là encore au milieu
d'un décor abandonner une enveloppe une
facture sans destinataire
et quand les chantiers de stelios
l'entrepreneur sont à l'arrêt ce sont
ces ouvriers albanais qui n'ont plus de
travail
aujourd'hui le patron reçoit son quart
lors le plus fidèle angel no cela fait
huit ans qu'ils travaillent ensemble
bonjour stellio sauf qu'il va bien ça va
et toi cas là ou pas on fait aller
stelios l'entrepreneur comprend qu'un
jane on est venus lui dire au revoir à
lorsqu'il part où tu pars pas oui je
vais partir qu'est ce que tu veux que je
fasse ya plus de travail en albanie oui
il ya du travail mais le problème là-bas
c'est que personne ne me connaît comme
500000 albanais angelino a fait sa vie
ici
il habite en grèce depuis 20 ans la fin
d'une époque
vous êtes triste de partir
oui je suis très triste parce que quand
tu travailles depuis huit ans avec
quelqu'un tu les aimes bien à la fin
quand on repense entre les deux hommes
le silence s'installe
si pour angelo le départ et si
douloureux ce n'est pas uniquement parce
qu'il va quitter son patron
l'ouvrier a aussi deux enfants fiona et
giorgos qui sont nés en grèce et qui ne
sont pas préparés à partir
qu'est ce tu veux toi creuse lors sa
fille parle avec lui en grec
elles ne maîtrisent pas bien la langue
albanaise elle va repartir avec vous au
pays oui elle va me suivre dans moins
d'un mois
toute la famille aura quitté la grèce
sans salaire en jean ou n'arrivent plus
à payer son loyer ni ses factures
oui j'ai beaucoup d'affaires à emporter
aujourd'hui on quoi on en est c'est
mieux en albanie vraiment mieux ici il
n'y a pas de travail du tout quand je
dis pas de travail ça veut vraiment dire
rien nada là bas on peut travailler
facilement au moins pour quelques jours
l'albanie un des pays les plus pauvres
d'europe lui offre plus de chance que la
grèce angelo s'est fait une promesse
revenir un jour à athènes
peut-être après la crise
m
quand il travaillait angelo a construit
une partie de ces immeubles dans le
quartier de tave loges zakaria 43 ans
deux enfants il vit depuis trois ans
dans un appartement imaginé par son amie
kate il architecte elle rentre du
travail
c'est l'heure des courses
[Musique]
posés ça ici
oh
kate et achète en petites quantités au
jour le jour
elle est fonctionnaire une place très
enviée il y a deux ans encore
aujourd'hui j'ai pris peu de choses il
me faut entre 600 et 700 euros par mois
pour la nourriture
l'accueil stone bea trophée l'argent
part vite j'ai acheté des aubergines
je vous fait votre menu préféré
zakaria travail au ministère des
finances où les salaires étaient les
plus élevés de la fonction publique
mais avec la prise l'état grec a inventé
le salaire dégressif and drug séquelles
mais ça il y a deux ans je gagnais 2300
euros par mois se raccroche alors
maintenant je touche près de 1700 euros
par mois et ça ne va pas s'arrêter là et
pour approcher malade dans un an je
n'aurai plus que 800 euros par mois
prochain alors 800 euros alors que la
traite de la maison et 2000 euros par
mois pour encore 27 ans il est 4 heures
panayotis 13 ans rentre de l'école il a
commencé très tôt sa journée à 6 heures
du matin
ces dernières semaines quand il rentre
il a faim ils ont supprimé la cantine
avant on avait à manger gratuitement
maintenant la mairie n'a plus d'argent
la cantine a disparu les bus de l'école
seront supprimés à la fin de l'année
avec the rocket et après je ne sais pas
ce qui se passera pour l'école car ils
ont déjà fermé plusieurs écoles
publiques
en plus tu sais ils vont couper le
chauffage
aujourd'hui ils ont allumé mais ça ne va
pas durer ils ont dit pour le quotidien
les parents de zakaria donne un coup de
main je crois que mes casseroles à te
laisse mes parents m'en vois de l'huile
d'olive de mon île natale à prononcer
t'imagines si je devais acheter mon
huile d'olive et le poisson que l'on
mange c'est mon père qui me l'envoie il
est pêcheur le fait de dépendre de mes
parents à mon âge quelque part ça me
fait honte pour s'en sortir
zakaria pourrait faire comme beaucoup de
grecs repartir vivre chez ses parents
[Musique]
quand les grecques voient s'effondrer
leur niveau de vie et se retrouve pris à
la gorge pas étonnant que la colère
s'exprime violemment dans la rue les
premiers visés ce sont les hommes
politiques parce que les événements pour
s odysseas vous nourrissez députés il a
vécu plus de 30 en france
c'est un proche du socialiste georges
papandréou encore premier ministre au
moment où nous tournons il y a deux
semaines
notre député a été pris à partie c'était
le 28 octobre dans un défilé le jour de
la fête nationale
sa femme a pris des photos là c'est
quand il a été obligé de quitter le
défilé il a dû s'enfuir avec l'aide de
la police
après nous nous sommes retrouvés au
poste de police
mes enfants étaient nerveux mon fils
aîné était très mal une photo qui
symbolise à elle seule la difficulté
d'être un homme politique en grèce
ce jour là le pays a vécu un véritable
séisme à thessalonique
le défilé a tourné à l'émeute le
président de la république que l'on voit
de dos ici a failli être lynchés par les
manifestants
takuya ce jeu les autres êtres casse toi
sale bâtard
il est exfiltré en catimini du jamais vu
pour un homme extrêmement populaire qui
incarne l'unité du pays quant au député
vous nourrissent ils se pensaient
compris des grecs et revient de loin
c'est un paradoxe que des gens comme moi
il y en a d'autres qui sont entrés en
politique il ya deux ans pour changer ce
système soit confondue avec les autres
voiliers l'alien est un énorme travail
de clarification affaire qui n'a pas
encore été fait dans la société grecque
aujourd'hui nouvelle épreuve pour le
député ils seront à l'assemblée
nationale avec son attachée
parlementaire en moto
c'est d'en faire
en moto
athènes chaque jour il y à des
manifestations
[Applaudissements]
une atmosphère de révolte souffle sur la
capitale pour éviter que les élus ne
soit agressé la police encercle le
bâtiment
bon
aujourd'hui on vote la confiance au
premier ministre georges papandréou
juste avant d'entrer en séance le député
vous nourrissent reçoit un message de sa
femme est ta femme cristina qu'est ce
qu'elle a dit elle a été très directe
elle m'a dit de voter contre papandréou
non mais ta femme tu sais ce qu'elle m'a
dit c'est la honte de savoir comment
nous allons ensemble faire la peau à
ceux qui boivent le sang du peuple
un seul slogan nous unit le peuple ne
paiera pas la dette est l'ennemie c'est
la crise économique qui a franchi les
frontières 7,7 ennemis se rapproche de
jour en jour de notre capitale il faut
qu'on réagisse le plus rapidement
possible on n'a pas là on n'a pas le
temps politique pour organiser des
élections pour savoir comment qui sera
le général il faut maintenant qu'on fait
tous d'accord qu on écarte le danger
immédiat et ensuite on ira bien entendu
aux élections
le peuple contre ces élus il est deux
heures du matin c'est la fin d'une
longue journée pour le député
un énième jour où la grèce a failli
basculer dans le chaos dans le
collimateur des manifestants il n'y a
pas que les hommes politiques
l'autre cible ce sont les nantis comme
les riches armateurs grecs
nikos vers nikos est à la tête de la
première société de remorqueurs du pays
et possède une centaine de voiliers
la crise lui il ne connaît pas son
affaire de la journée
la vente d'un luxueux yacht à un client
français l'aura beaucoup d avantages
pour vous qu il pense
ok un investissement d'un million
d'euros il y a de quoi soigner sa
clientèle
même en crise ont fait qu'on peut faire
dans le temps les gatinois là tout à
fait parce que il ya un proverbe qui dit
historique à l'opéra dans une traduction
libre
sachons digue contre pauvres il faut
bien à lui j et quand tu es riche peut
être encore plus regardées nikos vers
nikos aujourd'hui c'est pour un magazine
français qu il prend la pose
l'air satisfait depuis le début de la
crise le gouvernement a augmenté les
impôts pour tous sauf quand les amateurs
ils ne payent déjà aucune taxe sur les
bénéfices
et quand on leur demande s'ils ont
l'intention de mettre la main à la poche
ils répondent non et se font même
menaçant si des gens comme un bel album
n'était pas favorable
c'est très probable qu'une blonde partie
des sociétés d'armement qui sont basés
au pirée en grèce
on va bouger pour aller dans d'autres
territoires plus
jamais qu avec le tourisme la marine
marchande est un pilier de l'économie
grecque c'est aussi un lobby puissant et
opaque
impossible par exemple de connaître le
chiffre d'affaires de monsieur vernis
côté comme ça
casque olympio de 15 est révoltant
combien
on évite de parler d'argent parce que
les valeurs changent tellement vite
d'un jour à l'autre on regarde notre
travail et on voit pas la valeur de nos
biens et la valeur des actions de nos
sociétés nikos vers nikos n'aime pas
parler d'argent mais ils ne se cachent
pas pour le dépenser
à deux pas du port du pirée il s'est
offert un musée des créations
contemporaines qui peuvent atteindre les
20 mille euros cette oeuvre la seml
propre profil toutes ces oeuvres d'art
là encore l'armateur jovial refuse d'en
dire le prix il en est une qui résonne
particulièrement avec la situation du
pays le titre de cette oeuvre
c'est le temps c'est de l'argent
malheureusement la grèce aujourd'hui n'a
ni le temps ni l'argent c'est pour ça
qu'on en ait la main tandis qu'une
poignée d'amateurs continue à prospérer
il n'y a jamais eu autant de monde à la
soupe populaire mairie pini est une
bénévole d'une soixantaine d'années
depuis deux ans elle vient distribuer
les repas dans le centre d'athènes
qu'est ce qu'on mange aujourd'hui du riz
aux épinards chaque jour mille cent
repas sont distribués ici
non non non ont fait la queue ils vont
finir par se manger entre eux elle
allez avance donne mon autre s'il te
plaît s'il te plaît depuis quelques mois
dans la file d'attenté
une autre population s'est mêlé aux
immigrés des grecs modeste chômeurs aux
retraités de 10 % ils sont passés à 30 %
des demandeurs
bonjour madame maria comment allez vous
ça va ça va les canaillous c'est une
grand mère qui avait un fils de 45 ans
qui est mort d'un cancer
c'est a fait sonner en effet il lui a
laissé une femme et deux enfants là
qu'est un la grand mère vend des billets
de loterie
la belle fille et femme de ménage la
grand mère prend la nourriture et le
soir elle la met dans la casserole comme
ça quand les enfants reviennent de
l'école ils trouvent la casserole plein
quand mary pini nous raconte l'histoire
de ces grecs naufragés qu'elle connaît
c'est un peu ses propres angoisses
qu'elle nous livre dans mes pires
cauchemars
il me traverse l'esprit que ça pourrait
être moins à leur place
au train où vont les choses
moi aussi je pourrais me retrouver ici
moi et mes collègues car mairie pini
n'est pas une bénévoles retraités
elle est journaliste depuis 32 ans dans
un grand quotidien grec
il s'appelle eleftherotypia c'est
l'équivalent du journal libération
un titre engagé qui est né en 1975
juste après la dictature des colonels
dehors une banderole donne le ton une
partie de la rédaction est en grève
les salaires n'ont pas été versés depuis
trois mois
dès son arrivée elle est prise à partie
par son chef qui implore son aide avec
les impôts prélevés à la source
il ne sait pas à combien s'élève son
dernier salaire touché l'été dernier je
suis complètement perdue dans tout ça à
voir le comptable mais j'y suis allé je
n'en sais pas plus ce qui est écrit sur
le papier c'est qu'ils m'ont versé la
totalité du salaire mais c'est pas du
tout le cas aujourd'hui mais ripping
écrit un article sur les enfants grecs
qui sont victimes de la crise c'est l'
agence de presse nationale qui le
raconte dans une dépêche à missolonghi
il y a une histoire d'enfants qui vont à
l'école à jeun ils ont tellement fin
qu'il tombe dans les pommes en classe
j'ai entendu une histoire similaire dans
ma région
les parents d'élèves ont demandé à
laisser leurs enfants plus longtemps une
colonie de vacances parce qu'il n'avait
pas assez à manger chez eux mais tu
parles de grecs
oui oui des grecs dont les parents ont
été licenciés continuer à raconter la
crise quand on est soi-même touchés
c'est ce que font tous les rédacteurs de
ce journal ils savent que les
stéréotypes ya risque de fermer d'un
jour à l'autre
prenez ce bureau pour chacun d'entre
nous ce qu'il ya de plus important dans
la vie c'est la famille et le travail
c'est notre idéal c'est toute notre vie
si on arrête de travailler on est fini
je ne peux pas m'imaginer ne pas venir à
mon travail parce que je ne suis pas
payé c'est pour cela que toute l'équipe
fait un effort pour garder la rédaction
de boue
travailler sans espérer aucun revenu
quand un pays abandonnent chacun à son
sort comment avoir confiance en la
classe politique
nous retrouvons odysseas boulouris
le député réformateur ce document quand
il a été élu pour la première fois en
voici la voiture de fonction qui lui
était attribué une mercedes noire haut
de gamme beaucoup de députés ont reçu le
même modèle
alors que le pays était déjà en faillite
[Musique]
et je comprends pas comment des
collègues peuvent circuler en mercedes
noire et aller dans les villages où on a
réduit les les retraites
à 200 300 ou 400 euros et circulait en
mercedes et c'est tragique
comme ces tragiques comme message il
décide alors de refuser la voiture en
échange on lui donne cette berline elle
coûte deux fois moins cher
odysseas boris veut aller encore plus
loin
à l'heure actuelle un député en grèce a
un salaire de l'ordre de 8000 9000 euros
moi je dis donnons un député un salaire
tel qu'il existe dans la fonction
publique
2000 3000 euros au maximum et pour le
reste couvrons lui les frais sur facture
les propositions de loi du député vous
duris sont restées lettre morte
difficile de changer un système où les
privilèges sont la règle
[Musique]
dans une grèce paralysée
que peuvent faire les familles pour s'en
sortir pour des milliers de citadins
la seule solution c'est le retour à la
terre manolis habite et havre au syli
encore deux mois
c'était un voisin de zakaria la
fonctionnaire il était chauffeur de taxi
avec la crise il a perdu la moitié de
ses recettes
désormais c'est un troupeau de moutons
qu'il conduit dans le village natal de
sa femme les routes d'athènes n'avait
pas de secret pour lui ici il a un peu
de mal
sa dalle elles sont partis ou les
biquettes elles sont descendus au
village
[Musique]
mais quand est ce qu elles sont parties
bon ok j'y retourne les gants c'est un
peu difficile
en fait c'est vraiment difficile
j'espère que les bêtes vont vite mme
apprendre le métier sauter d'un grand
village un petit village et c'est pas
facile
chirac 70 personnes nées en sachant tout
mais moi ce métier de berger
je la prendrai regardez alors le chien
ils sont où les moutons sur la route il
rencontre un vieux copain de village
installé à athènes torche à la main
j'ai vendu mon taxi j'ai dû revoir je me
fait la malle et ça te plaît ici
attends je passe de l'enfer au paradis
et tu me demandes si ça me plaît je
demande ça parce que moi aussi je suis à
deux doigts de m'installer ici manoli
s'est installé ici pour de bon avec sa
femme et son fils à la campagne on vit
frugalement et on s'endette le moins
possible les paysans n'aime pas vivre au
dessus de leurs moyens on a donné à
notre pays le goût de la vie douce grâce
au crédit
on nous prêtait on nous prêtait et
maintenant on se retrouve le couteau
sous la gorge
plus on ne savait pas mais c'est de
notre faute
qu'est-ce qui a voté pour eux ouais
c'est vrai c'est nous qui avons voté
pour
qui est responsable pourquoi le pays at
il sombré retour à athènes
c'est le sujet de discussion à la
taverne du quartier de tave roos autour
d'un verre grigoris le vendeur d
manquait-il architectes zakaria la
fonctionnaire d'hélios entrepreneurs
viennent d'apprendre que le premier
ministre papandréou va démissionner
[Musique]
c'est du pareil au même
ce soit la gauche ou la droite ce sera
la même chose même changera moi je veux
un pro qui puisse parler à merkel comme
à sarkozy on aura un gouvernement qui
fera exactement ce que les français et
les allemands lui redonneront les
européens ont découvert que si on
tombait eux aussi je tomberai et tout le
monde tombe rade
vous savez les gars qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est impressionnant 58 %
des allemands veulent jeter hors de
l'europe
nous les grecs on a grandi avec l'idée
que c'est jamais notre faute c'est
toujours la faute des autres
le seul peuple innocent pur c'est les
grecs on est toujours victime d'une
conspiration mais je ne suis pas
d'accord avec ça on est pas tous
responsables tout le monde s'en est mis
plein les poches
sauf moi soffritti
une soirée qui s'achève dans les rires
pourtant demain la vie sera encore plus
dur avec moins de salaire et plus
d'impôts
tout un pays à reconstruire un cap
européens à maintenir
[Musique]
ah bon